and which TV show did I make my
on-screen debut uh Law and Order Sex in
the City ER you are from New York and I
know there's a lot of Law and Order and
I could see you playing like a super
beautiful young victim of something so
I'm gonna go with law order
let's go baby
yeah yeah you know you're going places
when you when you book your first
episode yeah episodic you're like you're
like and I would have gotten away with
it too if it weren't for you yeah yeah
yes I killed him yes I killed him it was
more like this like you know he did it
so just say it admit it
like great can we do it again this time
will really amp up the Queens but do it
in a way that you actually hate Rosie
Perez would you want me to say it in
Spanish yes
and I booked it